I'd recognize the gentleman from vont Mr
Sanders for two minutes gentleman from
Vermont mr. Sanders is recognized for
two minutes without objection Thank You
mr. chairman it's the Chairman I rise in
very strong opposition to the proposal
presented by the Republican leadership
at a time when this country has a very
large deficit and a four point seven
trillion dollar national debt it is
Volga it is crass to be giving huge tax
breaks to the wealthiest people in this
country and to the largest corporations
it is unacceptable that half the tax
breaks in this proposal go to people
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
or more and that the wealthiest one
percent will receive more in tax breaks
than the bottom sixty percent it is
pathetic that any time when the richest
1% of the population own more wealth
than the bottom ninety percent and when
the upper four percent of ernie's make
more money than to the bottom fifty
percent of earners that taxpayers making
over two hundred thousand dollars a year
receive a tax break of eleven thousand
dollars while those making less than
thirty thousand receive a tax cut of one
hundred and twenty four dollars and the
rich get richer and everyone else gets
poorer mr. speaker it is especially
outrageous to be talking about tax
increases for the rich when we all know
that it was the huge tax breaks for the
richest 1% in the 1980s that was a major
cause of the explosion of the deficit
during that period as a result of tax
breaks given to the wealthiest one
percent the Treasury Department loss of
1.5 trillion dollars between 1990 1981
and 1992 1.5 trillion dollars in tax
breaks to the richest 1%
during the 1980s and guess what in the
1990s their cousin buys expired more tax
breaks for the very same people same
gentleman from California